habe ich jetzt gibt es ja schon längere
diskussionen darüber über die
sogenannten sonderrechte für geimpfte da
ist die erste frage sind sonderrecht
überhaupt das richtige wort dafür
und wäre das in deutschland möglich zu
sagen sobald man durchgeimpft es darf
man auch wieder ins restaurant alle
anderen müssen eben draußen bleiben
also ich halte sonderrecht licht für das
richtige wort in dem zusammenhang es
geht darum dass grundrechts
einschränkungen die im augenblick
bestehen wieder aufgehoben werden
und eine solche aufregung ist
verfassungsrechtlich vorgeschrieben wenn
es keinen grund mehr gibt um
einschränkungen aufrecht zu erhalten
heißt also wenn grundrechts
beeinträchtigungen begründet werden mit
einem schutz vor der pandemie vor einer
ausbreitung des neuartigen corona virus
und leute nachweislich nicht zu dieser
ausbreitung beitragen dann sind weitere
beeinträchtigungen nicht mehr möglich
glauben sie dass diese debatte bei uns
gerade auch vielleicht geführt wird weil
man ja ablenken möchte das gar nicht
genug impfstoff da ist also ist das
womöglich auch eine politische
nebelkerze
ich bin mir nicht sicher diese
diskussion wirklich von der politik
gestartet wurde wurde ob die diskussion
nicht mehr aus der öffentlichkeit in die
politik hinein getragen wurde weil eben
eine große sehnsucht nach normalität
besteht der impfstoff eben unser
einziger weg in richtung dieser
normalität ist und die leute natürlich
sagen gut wenn ich mir schon überzeugen
lasse mich impfen zu lassen dann möchte
ich wenigstens auch sofort meine
normalen rechte zurück das ist denke ich
sofort verständlich
das heißt wenn man geimpft ist in ihren
augen sollte man dann sozusagen auch
klagen dass man eben wieder raus möchte
wie viele chancen hat man vor einem
gericht damit dann oder
restaurantbesitzer wenn sie vor gericht
ziehen
es kommt ein bisschen auf den
lebensbereich also was man sich nicht
mehr haltbar ist sind zb kontakt
beschränkung in den privaten bereich
wenn sie im märz geburtstag feiern und
alle ihre gäste sind gibt dann ist es
aus meiner sicht nicht vorstellbar dass
dann noch bußgelder verhängt werden oder
dass sie kontrollen befürchten müssen in
diesem zusammenhang
was ein bisschen schwieriger ist die
frage ob restaurants kinos etc öffnen
können oder wenn sie öffnen können dass
sie dann differenzieren können wenn sie
hinein lassen
da müssen sie aus meiner sicht erst mal
abwarten ob überhaupt mit der impfung
die übertragung des virus effektiv
unterbunden wird
mal angenommen das ist so dann ist die
nächste frage gibt es irgendwelche
möglichkeiten um diese auswahl an der
tür sozusagen zu verbieten
klassischerweise würde das eigentlich
nicht gehen also wenn sie denken an
klassische haus war situation an der tür
zum beispiel türsteher an klubs dann ist
es eigentlich gang und gäbe im privaten
bereich dass ich sie mir selber
aussuchen kann wenig bewirke wenig nicht
bewertet
dementsprechend ist die erste vermutung
aus juristischer sicht erst mal dass das
ganze zulässig ist also die
differenzierung zulässig ist zwischen
geimpften nicht gewünschten
vielen dank für ihre einschätzung zu
diesem thema natürlich wird das ganze
erst dann spannend wenn dann möglichst
viele menschen in deutschland schon
geimpft sind danke und einen schönen
abend ihnen noch mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren